through the city
like get the city
like and now
Brandon six
boy
sh what is popping fam 900 a.m. we'll do
it live freak it we'll do it live what
is popping Fellers and ladies mainly the
Fellers out there we know my demo a lot
of d dudes lot of dudes into the fight
game how you guys doing it is Monday
morning October 16th Halloween is coming
dude and if it's on on my TV it's only
scary Halloween stuff nothing else even
for the kids you have nightmares we're
watching Halloween stuff dudes that's
what we do Jim brought up the live feet
heard double voices and he fired and
that's how we're starting the morning
off he's
fired I am fresh off the road
that's right I flew to Sacramento and
then uh drove back because I was having
uh some work done on my TRX truck out at
Overkill in Sacramento they've turned
this thing into a straight
Banshee uh It Is by no means legal here
in California so we'll see how long I
can drive around without getting uh that
car impounded and arrested that's part
of the fun that is part of the fun
that's also California so we'll figure
it out we will figure it out um but we
shot all this content there with
Overkill uh with the whole build and
this is one of many I got uh I got the
creative juices flowing as far as the
car game goes so I'm excited for this um
that is the car which Chin's bringing up
he's bringing up my Instagram that's
right when I got there with the exhaust
with the headers the cat deletes um this
thing the goal was over 1,000 horsepower
we're we're about 50 horsepower over a
th000 so we're about 1050 we're about
1050 and uh it is um just a monster it
is this doesn't do it justice I know of
course Instagram doesn't do it that's
that's my problem with Instagram and
stuff it just doesn't even the sound
doesn't do it justice it if I revved it
out there it will we're we're going to
get
composed it's it get complain it's it's
like I can't drive this when I'm doing
sets at night because when I come back
home it still sounds really good here
yeah even that it sounds you're like oh
dang that's crazy no in person I was
like I looked at my brother I'm like
what are we going to do and he's like
it's too loud man I was like that's
exactly what I was going for so shout
out to Josh and the boys at Overkill uh
mission accomplished the overkill 1000
the first one ever built from them the
overkill 1000 but we're over a th so
it's we definitely they definitely
overkilled it because they went over a
th can we play this one here yeah you
can play so so what Chin's playing here
posos it which is playing here is uh
this is the first launch so the TRX
comes with a launch feature where it
allows you to launch the car from 0 to
60 quarter mile and it tracks all that
stuff so uh in the initial video which
you guys we have a whole episode of this
coming out in the initial video they
wanted me to drive Josh the owner TRX
who has he has the I think the 800 to
the 850 kit so still talking about 800
850 horsepower which is good but
then M's that plus a lot more right so
uh I get in his car and he launches his
and I freak out and we see it and freak
out he's like I want you to feel it I'm
like no no I want to wait till it's my
car that that's like that's the surprise
I want to feel the actual power once
it's my freaking truck so this this is
me and him launching my truck for the
first time um and you'll see it goes and
then I I was like oh my God and then I
he goes no no keep going then I it takes
off man it takes off but it was it was a
lot it was a lot and then the they have
the lights on because I got a add uh
bomber bumper put on the front and the
back those lights are for off-roading
which we're going to do we're shoot a
bunch of content off-roading this bad
boy it's just not a street princess but
when those lights are on I think we made
a mistake they think it's going to look
cool I think we it's so bright it it
looks it looks like in Street Fighter
when Ru goes Adin all you see is my car
when it when the camera they have a
drone in front you just see this big
flame going through the street so uh
this angle is the best cuz on the side
you can't see all the lights but uh it's
a lot man go ahead and play
it's so intense I got problems
man I'm like whoa and then it's on it's
just such a Banshee that is insane it's
insane it's been so fun man and it's
been so fun and the stuff I want to do
uh moving forward not this truck isn't
done but it's definitely damn near you
know there's bigger blowers you can do
there's other stuff you can do uh to get
to 1,200 1300 horsepower um but there
some stuff I've always want to do since
I was a kid with Lightnings with uh
typhoons Cyclones and uh it's going to
be fun man I can't wait I haven't been
this excited about something in a hot
second so uh it's fun man then J sha met
us up there I brought my oldest uh tiger
with us and so we drove up there or we
flew up there and then drove back and it
was just a a boy trip stay in the hotel
eating uh freaking beef jerky and big
gulps it was a good time man and we fly
back but again get get her a cop and
it's just like I'm there's no I might be
going 40 on a on the highway just cuz if
you go they're going to like what the
the hell is that I got hear this man oh
it's a sir it's a gargoyle do you mind
yeah it's we'll see we'll see how long I
can cruise around California that might
be the final straw when California goes
to impound my truck I'm like you know
what I'm just going to move to Texas all
right man you guys have pushed me away
but uh we'll see it was so much fun dude
uh just the the whole process says I met
so many dope people with all the brands
uh you everybody Ryan at kib Tech who's
right up the street which we're going to
shoot some stuff with him um the boys at
add um the Baja Designs toyot tires
method R Wheels um the whole thing has
just been just such a blast so uh I have
some ideas now it's time for me to give
back to you guys we we'll have some
announcements too coming up with that
whole show and all the automotive
content but I'm excited man uh one of
the re let's get right into the fights
one of the the reasons I drove back at
4:00 a.m. and woke up the entire city of
Sacramento leaving with my truck was
because I want to get back to make the
uh the uh Misfits card I guess is I
didn't know was Misfits yeah I didn't
even realize that Misfits yeah which is
KSI Tommy Fury was the main event which
no one really was talking about but the
the co-main event was um you know Logan
Paul Dylan danis the others I'm not even
getting into
um you know
we got to give them credit for selling
this fight the the magnitude of this
fight especially at the level they're at
in the fight game the the amount of hype
and the amount of eyeballs the amount of
traction it was something like I forget
what they said what Dylan dance has done
and the the amount of views that this
fight just on social media has uh gotten
it was it's something's crazy I want to
say it was like 15 billion Impressions
which is on her I mean I don't think you
fight has ever done that but it just
show and
again The Impressions is going based off
the Antics that Dylan danis did that
Logan Paul did that you know all the
people like me added to that you know I
was a small part of it but there's some
real big heads who are chiming in with
this you got schy having Dylan danis on
so from the comedy World The Sports
World the fight world you have everybody
all the Personalities in the space it's
just as big it we're in a soap opera
that's all we are we're in a soap it's
no different than WWE everyone has their
opinions you have your heels you have
your baby faces but at the end of the
day everybody's just trying to get as
much eyeballs as much money and Achieve
you know certain things so more kudos to
them so all that being said I think we
have to give credit where credits due
where no it's not Canelo vers Charlo no
it's not Usman versus hamzat it's Tech
technique wise fight Wise experience-
Wise of course it's not
that but we have to at least acknowledge
that these boys know how to sell a
freaking fight I almost said product
which clearly Prime's worth a one
jillion dollars which they know how to
do that but they know how to capitalize
on their fan base no matter what it is
whether it's Prime whether it's Dylan
danis you know whatever he's pushing uh
KSI whatever he's pushing so we have to
give them credit for that CU they are
Chang the landscape with a fight game in
that
aspect which I think is more good than
bad the reason why I'm careful with my
I'm I'm struggling with the I'm going to
be completely transparent I'm struggling
with being
positive because what we got on Saturday
as a as a guy who fought in the UFC for
quite some time you know at a high level
and been in sports for a high
level the product that you got is we got
to be be careful because it's not high
level in any aspect it's it's not a
quality product to production's
Quality the buildup of it is quality the
smack talk is you know quality depending
how you want to go effective that's a
better word is
effective
um so there's that but I I'm as as a
hardcore fight fan you know I bleed UFC
I I love One champion ship and those are
the sports at the highest level my fear
is we're going down a road
where that what you got on
Saturday and this isn't a knock on Logan
or Dylan or KSI or Tommy
Fury my My worry is that's going to
outshine and
overtake the legitimate
Fighters because what scares me is Logan
Paul Dylan danis Tommy Fury KSI
I don't even need to know the exact
numbers I'm sure we don't have them but
that will get more eyeballs than Hamza
versus kamaro this weekend it will get
more eyeballs than volkanovski versus
makev this weekend that will get more
eyeballs than Canelo and Charlo that
will get more eyeballs than Tyson Fury
and usk with guys who have spent a
lifetime of discipline and an entire
body of work that they're such outliers
they're so special
and then you have these guys because
they have this rabid fan base from
whatever it is YouTube uh one's salt
poppy you know he goes out there and he
he tries New York food and puts salt on
it and then decides he wants to be a
fighter you know
which again I'm I'm I I don't want to sh
I don't want to badmouth them but a as a
as a die hard and a in a and a guy who
loves this fight game I just have such a
fear that that is going to
overtake the actual
Fighters because they're not Fighters
they're they're just not
I it's tough man it's tough for me to be
cool here because what you're seeing is
a very very very
low-level um product when it comes to
fighting and and that includes Tommy
Fury he's he's just not he's not real
boxer he's not he has eight fights um
the reason why he's fighting these big
YouTubers is because I think a it's
brilliant what he's doing because at his
level 8-0 or whatever he is N9 and0 I
don't who gives a [__] okay whatever it
is whatever his record is at that low
level when you're coming up to the ranks
if he's fighting another kid who's 80
from Cuba another kid who's 80 from you
know Russia Ukraine those guys are dogs
man they eat sleep and breed that and
most of them are sleeping you know on a
mattress on the floor without any Wi-Fi
in a one-bedroom apartment trying to
make this dream Tommy fur's guy who's ha
and0 who's making millions millions and
millions and millions and you know he's
engaged to a beautiful woman who's
making millions and they're in this
Penthouse and his brother's the most
famous boxer on the
planet so if he were to if he really
wanted to be a real boxer again I'm not
saying he should but if he actually
wanted credibility in the space he would
step away from fighting the ksis step
away from fighting the Logan Pauls step
away from fighting the Jake Paul's and
go fight the no Namer from Dominican
Republic who's sleeping on dirt who's at
no and probably has a career in boxing
Tommy Fury's beating the game Tommy Fury
is the MVP of this entire thing
because for him to be 8-0 and to be
making multi-millions beting beating up
non boxers you did it dude you did it
you're 80 most people a guy who's 80 no
matter who your brother is nobody's
going to pay pay attention to you're
eight and0 and you're getting millions
of views and millions of dollars and
people are tuning in that's unheard of
so he's done it right I'm not saying he
should go down the path of fighting you
know some dude we can't pronounce in
Russia that nobody's going to watch I'm
not saying that I'm just saying that's
tradition how this goes and he's he's
fighting easy guys and getting big
paydays and getting a ton of eyeballs
and get more famous from it making all
the money off his Instagram like he he's
killing the
game the issue is is is what they're
doing taken away from the actual
fighters in the sport and that's what
worries me because again the the buildup
to this insane billions of Impressions
and then there's
no person in this space whether they're
an analyst like me whatever you want to
call me uh someone who enjoys UFC who's
been watching you know since the jump or
your big boxing head there's nobody
that's familiar with the fight game
who's watching that going man these guys
can
fight that's not a knock on them it's
just we're used to this and then we got
this so you're not getting any backlash
from the general consumer but Man Logan
Paul's one to insane he looks jacked man
Dylan danis this boy I thought KSA KSI
won that fight what what I I stopped
watching the KSI Tommy Fury fight after
the third round went I don't want to be
part of this I I'm good I'm I'm G spend
my Saturday afternoon doing something
else uh I'm good I'm all checked out it
didn't make me feel good again more
kudos to them and their fan base is
going to watch and eat it up you know I
and I don't know how far this can go but
again I'm not hating on it I think
there's a lane for it there defin this
Misfits thing there's a lane for it and
I also think it gives kids and young
people hope cuz when you see when you
see that salt poy when you see KSI who
was this nerdy this is him saying not me
this nerdy gamer who accumulated all
these massive followers and he's a damn
near you know worth $100 million do and
now fighting in boxing f a guy in Tommy
Fury as the main event and getting
millions of
views when I say you can do anything you
want that you can think of in the world
this shows you that KSI was this nerdy
introverted kid who went from that to
this when you see that literally kids
you can do anything you want to do this
is a good thing this gives people a lot
of hope these guys weren't born able to
run a 44 in the 40 they can't jump a
40in vertical they didn't grow up boxing
in the slums of Bronxville New York
there's none of
that that's out the window you don't
have to come from the gutters as Mike
Tyson says to become a fighter you don't
have to be a black belt and Jiu-Jitsu
under Marcelo Garcia Under henzo Gracie
you don't have to spend years and years
of when your friends are you know going
out and partying you don't have to stay
disciplined and not go party this is
they're showing you you there is a path
to do whatever you want to
do now are you going to be the best
fighter in the world the most technical
fighter in the world can you walk the
streets and pretend you're the bad a
badass no no no no those days are over
but you can get to a certain level and
get millions of views and millions of
eyeballs doing whatever the hell you
want to
do
kind of it could be a good thing could
be a bad
thing the day and age of saying and I
tell my son this all the time UFC
fighters don't come up in calabas
California and their dads don't drive
the cars your dad drives it doesn't
happen I can't use that
anymore Logan Paul and uh Jake Paul came
up pretty cushy you know not saying they
didn't have their struggles but they're
not coming from the slums they didn't
have no op fighting used to be a thing
where you have no other options well
these guys have all the options and they
still decide to choose to fight which
kudos to
them um when it comes to the you know
obviously the key takeaway of of that
night when it comes to to Logan Paul and
Dylan
danis I think one of the other things
that made this tough for me to watch
you're talking to a person who's biased
I do a podcast for God's sakes I'm not
live on a broadcast and I know how tough
it is if your friend or a guy who you're
you're close with is fighting not to be
biased that's not me that's why I don't
do professional
commentating the I don't know who it was
not Ariel did a great job and Ariel did
a good job bringing and they need a guy
like Ariel because he's as legit as we
have in our sport as far as journalism
goes so you need a guy like that
involved and he can kind of back up you
know proven that Dylan danis and argu
and Dylan danis is a a real fighter and
stuff like that but he he he does a good
job of educating them because they're so
far off on a lot of this but the main
commentator who anything Dylan Dan did
and it was just so PR Logan you can be
Pro Logan but you have to have an unbias
opinion as far as the broadcast goes
because that makes this even more of a
circus Dylan D would do anything like
dude I'll tell you the good luck against
Logan ball man and then Ariel's like
well I know his coaches were saying
because he worked with Alex Pierre his
coaches were saying go in there wear him
out in the first few rounds let him
punch himself out and then go to work it
was like the second or third round and
arel alluded to that goes I actually
talked to Pier Camp they said the game
plan was where let him punch himself out
and then go to work he goes well good
luck with that that ain't G to work you
have no fighting experience dude what
are you talking about it was just so
biased like dude you know you're not
gonna get a suck them off no matter how
hard you go on there right you know that
doesn't end like this you know it was I
was just like oh so I stopped watching
the I had to turn the volume down I was
like oh God damn it get off his nuts
dude you're not going to get a prime
chain bro it ain't happening you're not
that close to the boys back up dude just
be a little on biased for me to give us
more of a realistic product and I think
he's from the WWE and obviously they do
that stuff and that's part of the
problem and know want makes it even more
interesting again this is this is more
power to Logan Paul but he gets on there
and like so what's next for you he calls
out Ry Mysterio yeah check please I know
that was
weird of all things yeah excuse me sir
check please I'm out no no I'm done
watching it but KSI Tommy Fury's up next
I'm good he just called out Rey Mysterio
after a boxing fight but again Logan's
like dude this is my path I can jump
here I can jump this there so again kids
you can do whatever you want to
do whatever this proves to you when
someone tells you no matter what what
freaking tax bracket your parents are in
no matter what situation you're in the
single family home no matter what color
you are it not when I say this proves
you can do whatever you want to do this
is the living example and this is a good
thing
for Logan Paul to get in there and fight
Dylan danis in a boxing
match advertise and have his prime there
and then call out Rey Mysterio who's a
WWE
guy you can do whatever you want to do
and this is a good thing but I'm worried
it's going to ruin the actual Fighters
that's what I'm worried about so we'll
see I think there's a lane for it but if
that lane over shines the real Lane
we're we're going to be in some trouble
we could be in some trouble here because
look what it's doing the
boxing yeah Showtime's out HBO's out ESP
this was on ESPN dude ESPN plus
theone because if you're a businessman
you think they give a flying crap about
real boxing no no they just want
eyeballs and subscriptions so if we go
to them and go hey you can have Canelo
versus the other Charlo or Logan Paul
vers Rey Mysterio they go in boxing oh
we don't care who get brings more
eyeballs oh Logan crushes him give me
Logan and canelo's like what the yeah
yeah I know but that we don't get as
many eyeballs I know but I'm one of the
best ever do I'm one of the best boxers
of all time I know sweetie but Logan
Paul has 100 million subscribers you
know yeah so somebody has to put their
foot in the ground go hold on here hold
on it just can't be about YouTube clicks
and subscription we we have to at least
respect the
sport that's my only thing with that uh
when it comes to to Dylan
danis people like oh you called it I
think I guess
you
guess you called it exactly yeah he did
twice he did two different attempts a
take down and a choke yeah um
you know I wish I could brag or you know
but doesn't even mean being humble for
the rest of that didn't call us figure
it
out right figure it out this one was
easy as pie now the fights at UFC 294 be
a lot tougher to call and I'll try my
best but when it comes to this you know
YouTuber influencer stuff yeah yeah oh
did it end in a
DQ did he call out Rey
Mysterio okay okay oh you called it oh
cool that doesn't make me feel good I
did we all were fre like what the
immediately we were like holy [__] you
actually I didn't think it was a thing
but until my brother's like hey man
internet's going crazy if you call him
like really yeah we W make it the
title yeah I
mean yeah dude figure it out everybody
it's this nobody else called it what are
we doing you guys need to look yourself
in the mirror man what are we doing here
um can you take that for me CH I'll get
yeah okay fine yeah please man I'm in
the middle of all right go for it um go
back to the Misfits card you know I I
just you know as far as like what's next
for for Dylan
danis um you know most times again
coming from the a real fight background
most times when a guy performs like this
we're we're not gonna pay to see him
fight again so the UFC if let's say d
Dylan D is in the UFC let's say he's a
veteran has several fights gets to the
main event or gets to a title fight and
he fought like this you're going to be
disciplined you're going to be back on
the prelims you have to work your way
back up till we can trust you that's how
the real fight World works when it comes
to this Misfit stuff and people like
Dylan danis is done I don't think so
because again The Misfits teams going
right now in their they're in their
meeting today going who brought the most
eyeballs who who who made the most
Impressions Dylan danis let's give on
the next
card at the end of the day what the
Misfits represent isn't highle fighting
it's the Real Housewives of UFC The Real
Housewives of boxing it's a soap opera
and we're everyone's tuning into it and
everyone gets views from it so when
you'll see legit MMA
um Outlets go Dylan danis is done after
that
performance you're basing it off a UFC
model they don't play the same game so
that's no different than in the WWE if
guy loses going he's done he he he'll
never come back no this is this is how
it goes so Dylan danis isn't done I
don't want Dylan danis to be done he's
good for them he's good for them so
um I I would also hope hope obviously we
haven't been in here since all this
stuff popped off with with the USC 294
changes uh Logan Paul going after me as
far as saying you know uh there's no
suing and fighting all that stuff I like
Lo for the record I like Logan Paul I
like Jake Paul I like Dylan danis I like
KSI I like Tommy Fury but we're living
in a so propera so when I say something
they respond I don't take any of it
personal it's all for Impressions it's
all for clicks all for views if we're in
person I'm cool with all of them I don't
dislike any of them but I have a show
where I have to critique or I have to
comment on certain things so you know
when it comes to Tommy Fury kide Logan
Paul Dylan Denis for Logan Paul my only
thing was again and this is me coming
from a legit Sports background there's
no suing and fighting you as I
emphasized on Monday's
pod your payback no matter how nasty it
gets you have a chance to legally beat
the crap out of this guy and not go to
jail not go to prison that's the payoff
Logan Paul did that Logan Paul
embarrassed Dylan danis job well done
mission accomplished the LW that's done
throw that Logan You've Won dude in life
several times over your fiance is
beautiful your brother's crushing it you
live in Costa Rica or wherever the hell
he is Puerto Rico Puerto Rico same thing
you live in on an island you basically
run the island You've Won dude you've
won you've proven to us you can beat the
crap out of Dylan danis you've done it
dude this LW
suit drop it yeah it's over you did it
dude you did it you embarrassed Dylan
danis you did it bud that's it that's
where this thing stops because what we
don't want to have happen is in this
Misfits again there's a lane for this
the next time you fight slogan Paul
you're not going to get the same
Impressions you're not going to get the
same buildup cuz I'm going go I gotta be
careful man I'm gonna get sued that's
what we don't want this Misfits thing is
Big because of a guy like d Dylan
danis really is
so um you know what's next for Dylan
danis I he talked about the UFC I doubt
that ever happens I I just don't see it
when we see his boxing the the the UFC's
so past those days of just a pure
Jiu-Jitsu Guy having success in the UFC
name
one current like I'm saying in today in
2023 who can just have straight
Jiu-Jitsu no striking and get it done in
the UFC the gamees advance so much you
can't do it anymore yeah I mean Ryan
Hall was dope in the beginning but he
could how's he doing that I know exactly
Gracie how's he do exactly you you you
can't McKenzie dur Savage best J in the
female division Vision she had to adapt
her style and she got with at Ruka and
she's striking a lot more cuz there's no
way you can become champ based off
Jiu-Jitsu cron Gracie was like I'm just
gonna show Jiu-Jitsu Works how'd that go
this come from a Jiu-Jitsu guy I love
Jiu-Jitsu if all you have is Jiu-Jitsu
you're never gonna make it to the UFC
kids it's not happening in 2023 if it's
all you have yeah if that's all you have
if all you have is world class Jiu-Jitsu
and very amateur striking you're you're
never making a mixed martial
arts that formula doesn't work anymore
so for Dylan dannis with his injuries
stuff like it's gonna it's gonna be very
tough for the UFC to sign on that
especially after losing Logan
Paul true you know so but there there's
a lane for Dylan to keep doing this
stuff you're telling me you wouldn't
watch Dylan D
KSI when I say you I don't mean in here
I'm I'm talking to the no we're
different we're different but if to
Dylan D to build that fight up what he
did with Logan you'd watch
KSI you know and and and and also we
have in the society we live in we have
such short-term memories if he starts
going hard in the pain on KSI who knows
what angle he's going to take we're like
oh damn okay okay yeah dig up some crazy
stuff February 20 22 you know 20 on the
22nd Dylan danis KSI like okay all this
stuff I'm talking about something to do
something to do I I will say this man is
hats off the KSI Tommy Fury Logan Paul
Dylan danis because in the world we're
living right now in the war going on in
Israel and Palestine it's so heavy it's
so
dark that this was an escape from that
so kudos to them and it it got and it's
not that you want to turn a blind eye to
what's going on in the world but it's a
it's an Escape for two hours of really
what's going on and it is the darkest
nastiest evilest stuff that ever happens
in the world and it was an escape from
that when I see that
stuff I don't want to like my car stuff
the the truck stuff is escape from that
when when I see some of that stuff I
don't want to come on podcast and be
silly I don't want to do standup I don't
want to post about my stupid [__]
truck when you look at what's going on
in the world I don't want to do any of
that thatu is an escape for a short
second to really what's going on and
Dylan danis and Logan Paul as nasty as
that buildup was I want to thank them
that was an escape for two hours of real
problems going on at the end of the day
Logan Paul being Dylan danis in in the
grand scheme of things of what's going
on in the world none of it
matters none of it matters but he gave
us an escape for two hours so God bless
them man um you got some big fights
coming up this weekend
when I say big some of the biggest ever
happened and
uh yeah I haven't been in here since all
the news broke this real housewives of
um UFC that we're living in this this
was a a big weekend with with all these
fights you being announced you're
talking about a 10day notice
and I I'm I'm going tie this all into
one thing this about to be a long rant
and I'm going to tie it all into one
thing style Bender Israel OS came out
and said I'm not in an ounce I'm not
going to fight for a long time and I
thought that that's such a brilliant
mature choice of
Israel what's going on with with Israel
and what's going on with the UFC and
what UFC was able to pull off with uh on
a 10-day notice in replacing Paulo Costa
who fell out and putting in
um kamaro Usman
and with uh Charles olera falling out
and putting in Alex volkanovski with the
UFC what the UFC was able to do on a
10-day notice to replace with Kamar
Usman a world class one of the best
welterweights ever do it on 10-day
notice Alex volkanovski who's the
pound-for-pound number one guy in the
world on a 10day notice is absolutely
insane we should all be bending the knee
what Israel was able to do to be the
most active Champion for so long
fought so many times the best of the
best to lose to Alex Pierre then turn
around a short notice on a short a camp
and then knock out Alex Pier is so
insane yeah here's what's happening is
we're so accustomed to Israel doing that
we're so accustomed to Dana White and
the UFC pulling this off so that we get
great fights we're not giving them the
respect that they deserve and we just
assume this is how it goes this is not
normal what Israel OS has done at
middleweight at the highest level for so
long as many times as he's defended that
title as many times he loses comes back
loses comes back for him to do this and
be as active as he is because we're so
used to that we've lost sight of really
what's going on which is absolute
greatness and we've taken that for
granted so for him to step back makes
the heart grow fonder and the shame that
is going on right now is when somebody
retires whether it's Michael Jordan
whether it's LeBron James Tom Brady
insert big athlete um whe whether you
know whether it's Anderson Silva when it
was Brock Lesnar you this is I'm telling
you guys right now recognize greatness
when it's happening live in front of
your eyes don't wait till these guys
retire it's you're doing yourself such a
disservice so what's going on with
Israel and there's all these comments on
this stuff and you know he'll talk about
it on you know his Instagram he has a
YouTube channel and we've never seen a
champion be see be so open and tear down
that fourth wall and he let you inside
his world and he's this phenomenal
talent because you have access to Israel
adna who is possibly the greatest
middleweight to ever walk this Earth
because you have all this access to him
you're taking it for granted how special
he is and by him stepping way you're
going to realize what a special athlete
what a special human he is this exactly
what he needs to do and Dana is never
going to get his Kudos the UFC is never
going to get their kudos for them to
have two of the main event and co- event
Fighters fall out on 10 days and then
replace it with kamaro Usman and Alex
vosi is nothing shy of pure greatness
but you guys are used to that so we go
oh cool you're driving oh new fight cool
you don't realize how cool that is and
it's a shame you don't realize how great
is he is and it's a
shame so these guys have to go through
these weird transitions for you to
finally recognize what what you got all
these years of pure greatness is he's
not a guy that doesn't you know he's not
a guy that misses weight he's not a guy
that doesn't take on the the number one
Contender he's not a guy who who says
he's going to do thing and pulls out a
fight injured he's not that guy but you
guys got used to that guy and you go ah
it's just is he fighting little do you
know that he is one once in a
generational talent and you we've all
taken it for granted so when he goes I'm
gonna take a step back not fight for a
while I thought oh that's brilliant let
people go damn where's Izzy man what
what happened to Izzy cuz before it was
just like oh is he's fighting three
months crazy he just fought right y damn
is he lost to Alex he's fighting him
again yeah yeah damn is he knocked Alex
out yeah man that was amazing damn is he
on short not us fighting Sean Strickland
yep yep yep and he told the UFC to do it
UFC didn't want to do it damn that's
crazy then he loses oh is he's done no
no no you guys didn't recognize the pure
greatness when he was doing it when he
was in the middle of it and you've done
yourself a disservice so him taking a
step back he goes I'm trying to do as
much as I can but after this fight and
again 14 months four fights 14 months
four fights as the most famous man in
the UFC is onard of and you guys want to
trash Izzy you're [__] you guys that
are bad mouth and Izzy
[__] look because you look at the
massive stars in look when's the last
time Connor fought and I love Connor we
don't know what's gonna
happen you look at these big superstars
look at them how active are they are
they taking on
all customers are they taking on all the
badasses Izzy cleaned out I he was so
great you didn't realize how great he
was he lapped the
competition fought Robert Whitaker
twice vtori paoc Costa he lapped the
competition the UFC had to sign a
fighter from Glory who beat him in
kickboxing and FastTrack him to the
title shot to get yall interested in his
fights that is the definition of pure
greatness and y'all are missing it and
y'all want to make fun of them you want
to badmouth them no no no Izzy gave you
so much access we've never seen a guy of
his level give so much access break down
the fourth wall you took it for ADV you
just assumed that this is how it goes
now you you're going to learn he's once
in a life time generational Talent
nobody's like Izzy he's not I know he
lost I know look at his resume for God's
sakes there's nobody better to ever do
it at 185 pounds this guy can lose and
then come back and win the the what he
did against Jan bovich insane dude he
came back when his next fight what he
did against Alex Pier you know the
mental fortude you have to have you're 0
and three yeah and then they're like
well it's just kickboxing and then he
knocks you out in MMA and then to take
that fight on a few weeks later and then
knock him out playing rope
Adobe y'all must have forgot and he's
going to remind you because now he's not
going to be in there for a while and
you're gonna have the rest of the
middleweight division who ain't Izzy
they're fun they're not Izzy so he needs
to sit back
recoup distance makes the heart grow
fonder and then come back and prove his
greatness
same thing with what Dan and the UFC is
doing there's nobody else on 10 days
notice who can fill in these massive
massive fights and you're talking about
historical fights on 10 days notice it's
insane for Alex vosi to step up and do
it for kamaro Usman step up and do it
you're talking about the biggest wos to
ever fight in the UFC it's nutso what
we're getting you guys need to recognize
that not just go H what are the odds
what's the draftking odds did but just
take a step back and realize what these
guys are doing for you the fans win the
UFC
wins something you should also recognize
is whenever it's a a fight in Abu Dhabi
or in the Middle East or it's a fight in
Australia the UFC has a deal with them
they're getting so much money they they
have I forget how many pay-per-views
that they agreed to in their agreement
they have to provide Superstar fights so
if this fight was at T-Mobile Arena this
fight was at the UFC Apex
PS you're not getting Alex
vosi versus makev that's not happening
they're not going to risk that you're
not getting um uh hamzat vers uh Kamar
Usman Kamar Usman they're not calling
him you're not getting that you're
getting probably top 20 guys like 15
through 25 to step in and just get
slaughtered and they go all right let's
just focus on the next one but when it
comes to Australia and Abu Dhabi they
have made promises to them that give
them Blockbuster fights and that's why
you got these
fights they have to do that they can't
just insert no Neer who gets slaughtered
they can't do they can do that here in
America but when it's International when
it's the Middle East when it's Australia
they have contracts there's language in
those contracts where they have to give
them BigTime fights and that's one of
the reasons you're getting these
fights that should be
noted I can't wait for this UFC 294 it's
GNA be awesome can't wait really quick
to piggyback on the Israel AOS stuff I
remember like you picked him to win
against Alex I think both times yeah uh
the second time I was
like I just I don't see how he can win
because he's he always has his number
right and you know I I told you
privately like I have a little bit of a
PTSD thing whatever that happened I
can't get over something when he
freaking knocked out Alex I was like it
gave me more like like dude there's a
chance to get over some stuff yeah so it
made that much an impact on me which was
incredible yeah yep yep yep no different
than what what Conor was doing that
magical run we've talked about here you
know Conor's changed my life forever you
know with that magical run and then I
got to deal with Showtime based off all
that stuff like there's certain Fighters
that they're once in a generational
Talent Connor was one of them Izzy's one
of them and you love the the build the
build the buildup and and with Izzy
again if you have a trained eye if you
don't have a trained eye but if you have
a trained eye he's so special man so
that's why I always fight for him he
because you guys you you have this
mythical creature walking this Earth
competing in the middleweight division
in the UFC get off his nuts I know I'm
telling you dude when you see that you
you it's hard for me to pick against him
no matter who it is dude you're like o
that dude is special man definitely he's
special he's special it's like when you
see Patrick Mahomes he does this crazy
throw like oh my God that's filthy it's
Bryce Harper for the Phillies back
toback home runs like my god dude this
is all the pressure on him he can pull
that off he's special he's different I
like that I root for those guys we need
those guys we need you to recognize how
special those guys are that's why I went
on this whole rant please recognize how
special what Dana White did and what
Izzy did and why Izzy needs time off you
guys took him for granted and now you're
all going to learn you you you missed
out so a you appreciate it
now NFL season is strong though say that
right now this is a segue NFL season is
going strong no teams are undefeated the
eagles the birds lost all right uh who
else lost Buffalo's been losing the ners
Lost shout out to Christian mcaffrey he
got injured that's why they lost I think
there's no undefeated teams left so
that's all good now anybody can win
anybody can lose and you can watch all
the NFL season and make bank with
draftking sports book They're hooking
new customers up with offer that's even
stronger bet five bucks on any game this
week score $200 instantly in bonus bets
and DraftKings isn't stopping there no
way all customers going to take
advantage of a sweet deal all right
every game day this October you got
Monday Night Football theight you got
college football popping don't bet on my
see Buffs they're just not ready for
this Limelight we were up 29 to nothing
watching in the hotel in Sacramento I
fell asleep woke up my brother's
throwing his TV remote uh they lost an
overtime so it's tough if you're a Buffs
fan right now but still doing better
than last year so be cool man get in on
the game day greatness download the
draftking Sportsbook app right now use
the code shop show scab show new custers
can score $200 instantly in bonus bets
when you bet five on the NFL that's Cod
shop show only on draftking Sportsbook
an official sports betting partner of
the NFL the crown is yours gambling
problem call- 1800 Gambler or visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net in New York call
8778 hope NY or Tex hope NY 467 369 in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 8887895118
/f terms for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming resources if you're still
listening to the show God bless you
DraftKings promo code shop show oh this
one's one of my favorite I'm happy to
welcome uh a new company I rock them all
the time it is sheath
underwear you've heard other brands on
the show as far as undies go there's
none better than sheath underwear it's
the best underwear I've ever worn every
time you hear my voice see me on stage
see me on podcast see me on show I'm in
my she freaking undies their stretchy
fabric is made of moisture wicking
technology and your boy sweats your boy
sweats it keeps everything cool
comfortable and right in place all right
sheath is particularly useful for
staying cool all right if you're working
out you're in a hot environment it's hot
as hell out here in calabases right now
but also keeps you warm comfortable dry
and cold environments across the board
they got you covered and I love their
dual pouch keeps your man Parts
separated even the big nose separates
separ separate from the balls if you
feel me all right sheath uses materials
like bamboo and mes for even more
cooling comfort you guys are going to
love them they have bamboo shirts
hoodies designed for maximum Comfort
they're all about Comfort sheath I swear
by just go to sheath underwear. comom
that's
shat underwear. comom right now use use
the promo code shab to receive 20% off
the best underwear your body has ever
felt by far Bar None that's sheath
underwear. comom use that promo code
today use the promo code shab for 20%
off sheath baby have you guys felt the
sheaths yet yeah I need some oh yeah
let's get some they send me another
little care package I go through
them I'm hard on my undies dude I expect
a lot of my undies sheath hold up should
you wear size larger X larger what do
you large chin for my seven-year-old
where is large what I wear double X
double X yeah holy crap I hate when
things are really tight yeah I well I
wear large large yeah that's me all
right so the biggest one of the biggest
news that came out kind of
personal for my waist dude not kind of
personal not the junk the waist what
dude large as you know whatever dude
anyway uh so apparently well not
apparently it happened usada is now
leaving the
UFC uh this is one of the biggest news
in MMA right now so in 2024 UFC is going
to be taking on a new thing with with
interrogator for Saddam Hussein really
that guy yeah that guy he's going to be
the head of that seems like this sucks
if you're a fighter this guy
interrogated
H also like sit down with him he's like
super into Jiu-Jitsu so I guess he has
like you know at least he does the sport
you know he he knows some something
about sport but uh he's going to head
the company listen shout out to Luke
Thomas he's been saying this forever
usada the athletes and the sports that
they that usada is known for and came up
using doesn't fit the the same
requirements for UFC fighters it was
always a disruption it was NE they was
always trying to fit a square into you
know a circle it was just never a fit
there's so many issues Jeff nitz is
great he was the best thing to come out
of usada the golden snitch was the best
thing come out of usada but usada messed
up man people already don't like I don't
know anybody who likes usada I I don't
know anybody but then for them to come
out and try to get in front of the story
and go at Dana on the UFC when I saw him
like o about to get ugly for usada
because nobody's better at spinning the
narrative and getting their message out
than Dana White in the UFC now usada
your BS to learn today dim the rules
buddy get used to this so they'll just
go off into the either and you know test
other athletes but yeah it's going to be
a
nightmare yeah now the rumors are a lot
of this conflict started with the Conor
McGregor debacle yeah but I think UFC
was just like you know it's so much
money we're good dude get out of here
yeah get out of here I also think it's
something to be said where remember now
they're folding into one company with
TKO with WWE and UFC so it's weird to
have this strict strict usada testing
with UFC and then WWE is the wild west
let's be honest no I know the hardcore W
they test shut up so they're doing the
wild west over here strict over here
under the same Banner let's just go and
fold these two in all right now I don't
know how strict the testing is going to
get there's definitely be still some
testing I don't think this is a
free-for-all where guys can just take
Deca and winst straw and fight you know
but I do think for UFC fighters there's
no off season so there has to be some
sort of standard in place where guys can
take performance performance-enhancing
drugs whether it's HGH with it some sort
of peptides to advance
recovery because they're not NBA
athletes with an off season where they
can heal and recover they're not the NFL
where there's this off season they're
not NHL they're not MLB they're UFC
fighters there's no offseason and they
get their bodies get absolutely
destroyed so uh look at look at how long
UFC Fighters careers I think it used to
be a year and a half so there's a reason
why their careers are so short so I
think the if it can aid in recovery
there we need to do that and I think UFC
as they've been on the Forefront of so
many things can be the first major
organization that can you know kind of
steamroll that and get guys peptides and
HGH and hormones to enhance
recovery um but again it's a slippery
road because then guys are going to
continue to use that when they're in
Camp everyone's going to take advantage
of the situation but there should be
something in place where they can do
that I'm going to surprise you with
something in a little bit but yeah yeah
I'm with you on that jinz all am on
steroids dude I I was on TT and they
took me off for like three months to see
because it's for fertility right they
said like just in case you know if you
have kids if you want to have kids just
take it off for a while my test levels
are still like like 900 or something
without trt which is kind of crazy
that's great yeah uh so this is what Jon
Jones said after this usada
announcement says man I survived usada
first they said I was guilty of having
Pico grams then let me go here there go
man I survived usada first they said I
was guilty of having Pico grams then
they considered me innocent next pics
became legal guess what I'm still here
still unbeaten the BS no contest over
dcas we take off my record I've never
cheated this sport I will stand by that
until the day I
die
so I have thoughts on this obviously
right what's your thoughts uh so he
popped like twice right he popped twice
one was Terin ball the other one was
like some other stuff yeah um and then I
remember when I saw the the post or the
press conference with nitzki and uh
Hunter Campbell yeah they were saying
like yeah we did trials we did tests
about um people took you know we did a
test where or they knew a test where
people took chopine a little bit of
chopine and then like years later they
still had picograms of
chopine in there but the thing is they
still took chopine right yeah which was
illegal at the time yeah so it's like so
you can't go back in hindsight that's
it's the same argument for Reggie Bush
and the nil deals where Reggie's like
dude you got kids making millions of
dollars off endorsements I took a free
Hummer and I lost my Heisman and you'll
see billbo on like give Reggie back his
Heisman it's like sure now but at the
time dimmed the rules at the time that
was what it was so so we can't go back
in hindsight and go yeah but now look
okay but at the time that was illegal at
the time you weren't allowed to take
that stuff we found that stuff it's
still we still got to hold you to
it not saying any of it's right but
that's kind of the rules back back then
you know yeah well and plus with Luke
Thomas's thing I'm a huge fan of Luke
Thomas but his thing is he's like very
specific about like it's not making the
sport safer there's no data to show that
but it's not that it's like the fair
play thing right like if remember you
fought lvar Johnson who popped right
after correct yeah you fought him beat
the brakes of them but I mean like that
Advantage you did grappled him for a
reason yeah cuz I knew on steroids I
didn't want to get hit in the face but
like they have the that's an advantage
if you're on steroids if you're on P
it's an advantage so that's that's the
thing that I think about but Luke
Thomas's argument is what's not making
it it's like it's like uh he was saying
like there's no data to show that
someone that's on steroids will mess you
up more than someone that's not there
data true will be hard to find because
the Bisping bisbing so the data and this
I think athletes would have a different
view on this
because vtor Bell for you could say um
whatever he was clean going in well how
he passed test going in cool but if he
did steroids all through camp in in what
steroids do again it's massive in
recovery it's massive where you know if
you're nonsteroids and you let's say you
Spar a Monday you're pretty beat up to
about Friday or Saturday and then
hopefully by the next week you recover
you're doing cold tubs cold plunges that
all the craze we've been doing for 30
years but anyway so you're doing all
this stuff just to recover to get
through camp and let's say you threw I
don't know 50 spinning back kicks that
first week and then the second week you
might have threw 20 the third week you
throw 10 because you're tired you don't
have the same
explosiveness well let's say through
just for bad numbers here let's say
through a hundred spinning kicks that
land that one that landed and knocked
you know knocked out uh knocked out
bisbing and made him blind took his eye
without took his eye without steroids
he's throwing let's say 1550 K with
steroids he's probably throwing a
thousand so it's so it's that repetitive
you're able to repeat repeat repeat at
the highest level repeat repeat no
diminish in return repeat repeat repeat
then you get in there and you're still
going to have that that's the advantage
it's not good and then throwing
EPO you start throwing epos and stuff in
and you're talking about cardio when at
that the top five guys at that level
like vodavi not steroids in a
facet his biggest asset in Dominic Cruz
allude to this one of his biggest assets
is his cardio it's his biggest weapon he
does not get tired that's exhausting for
guys now let's say Islam marev took EPO
and can matches not only matches cardio
but maybe go even a little higher well
now now now vonavi is screwed his
biggest asset is taken away because this
guy artificially created it when
Arlovski put in all the hard work so
that's why this stuff is a
problem yep 100%
agree um so I saw this article pop up so
as soon as uh Gordon Ryan found out
about you know usada leaving the UFC he
said it's amazing news right he said
there's so many benefits for it and you
basically said the same thing it's like
recovery all this stuff right it makes
better Fighters if everyone can be on it
and then well you want to I don't know
if you want to see all this entire thing
but um the UFC regresses back to the old
days this amazing news the reason people
watch profess Sports is all almost
exclusively for entertainment value
correct look at the Misfits few people
who watch Pro Sports have any real
desire to excel at those same Sports
yeah I don't know about that yeah that's
true otherwise they wouldn't be watching
so really they are just watching for the
most entertainment the higher the
testosterone The More Physical the
athletes are less prone to injury they
are yeah the faster they recover the
longer they can compete and the more
entertaining the high paced they are the
better they look the more attention they
draw the more money they make all true
all correct yeah what's the issue in
addition people think that just because
athletes are being tested by usada or
wada that they are natural laughing my
ass off uh with the amount of money
pride and Legacies in the line beating
drug tests has become multi-billion
dollar industry always has been this
means uh that the athletes who have
money are big part uh part of big teams
with resources needed are able to
actually beat the test correct which I
told exactly the reason I didn't do
steroids zes in the UFC I couldn't
afford it yes by the way I'm going to
bring you up after this B uh that has
historical been proven time and time
again this means top tier athletes have
money and resources to use Peds get away
with it up incomers don't that was your
boy this creates an uneven playing field
if there's no testing then every athlete
can use what he or she wants and the the
playe field is now level it's not level
I see what he's saying but still not
going to be level CU up incomers can't
afford it exactly so I saw this link
under this this is from 2015 this is
your statement on uh
PDS uh wow I don't know if you remember
this or not no I don't remember say this
I some wild [__] I freaking agree dude
this is like insane I'd love to hear an
argument for why why I shouldn't do
steroids say I'm a young kid and I asked
my dad dad why shouldn't I take steroids
can I say well you never uh you'll never
be World Champ that's not true and
Silva's World Champ will you never fight
for a title that's not true CH s Tes
fought for a title will you never be the
ultimate fighter coach nope Jay son and
Anderson Silva will you never be Main
Event no not true Alistar over's a main
event Bigfoot Silva's a main event God
look at me dropping facts dude well
listen you might you might get fired no
not really you guys pop all the time if
he's cheating everyone else is doing it
and they're getting rewarded for it
there's just no reason everyone
shouldn't take steroids someone gave me
a someone give me a legit reason why you
you would tell a young fighter not to
take them I would love to hear a good
argument will you get find 3,000 and
you'll have to sit out 6 months maybe
nine I fight every six months anyway boy
it's like so true dude like that's dude
that's a smart dude D 2015 2015 yeah I
would never like want people to take
steroids but like it's like the cost
benefit like come on well then imagine
the so imagine you're Dana White let's
say you own the UFC
let's say you own let's say you own the
Lakers you hooked up with Jenny bus and
busted in her and then you have a kid
and you're in tight with them LeBron
James makes that organization all the
money in the
world if I told you LeBron could play
five more years at the highest level
possible but he has to take HGH and
igf-1 and
steroids and you're going to make I
don't know a billion dollars or we can
drug test them hardcore and he's
probably just going to be a shell of
himself for the next three
years what are you going to do yeah if
you're the UFC and go hey man Izzy can
fight for the next 15 years if you just
or Conor can come back and fight and you
make all the money just got to kind of
turn a blind eye to what he's doing
you're not going to do
it I again I haven't heard a good
argument why they shouldn't take
steroids that fact these guys can get
concussed that was ex they're going to
do it anyways
that was insane yeah 2015 you did that
dude that's like I'm in the game hot
second dude huh that's that's crazy I'm
more proud of that than I am calling the
Dylan danis fight right dude you should
be I never would have thought Dylan was
gonna do a freaking choke oh yeah yeah
no
whatever that's why it's tough to bet on
these fights man there were odds though
there were odds that did Dylan was
getting DQ and if you guys would listen
to me you made so much money but um
sometimes I'm right most time I'm wrong
I'm like Drake okay uh but if you want
to uh listen to actual experts
especially when it comes to Fantasy
Football UFC NFL MLB Texas Rangers beat
uh Houston Astros I got my two favorite
teams Arizona and the Phillies are
playing tonight let's go Phillies um if
you want to bet on those games listen to
actual experts that's why I partnered up
with fanasy Guru all right they're legit
experts giving you legit facts they got
the odds they got everything going on
listen to them don't listen to me or
Drake all right just go to fancy
guru.com use the code shop for 20% off
to get all the legit insights so you
make more money these are legit experts
it's all they do all right go to the
fancy guru.com promo code is shab for
20%
off um dropping facts and in 2015 I was
dropping facts and a lot of it is thanks
to happy hippo all right whether you see
me on a pod you see me on stage whatever
it is your boys on that crom I swear by
crom and I don't trust just anybody it's
happy hippo happy hippo.com prom codes
thick 23 thick with three C's you get
20% off for freaking life and you can
use that code as many times you want
share with a friend family member cousin
your gay ant I don't care that's Happy
hippo.com promo code is thick 23 for 20%
off for as much as you want the K dips
they're Taffy they got powders they got
gummies they got it all and it's the
only company that I trust in the wild
west of catom it's happy hippo.com promo
codes th23 let's get back to the program
CH I think that's it for current events
uh we have uh we got Adrian pearon
coming on fire the kid at 10:30 now how
much of this episode is Brian just gonna
talk about how strong the quads are and
not talk football it's about to drive me
nuts let me ask you real quick though do
you want to do a couple questions or no
no it's GNA be tough right we're tight
okay yeah let's just get through this uh
so you got your your your big UFC 294
going down this freaking Saturday man I
so excited for this card it is stacked
from top to bottom the UFC came in saved
the day all right uh says it starts at
11:00 a.m. Pacific time yeah super early
because it's in Dubai right yeah um so
you have said nurov fighting you got uh
warley Alves fighting interesting magod
uh fighting Johnny Walker dude that main
card is so freaking t
it is the best main card I think this
year the names are so T to pronounce but
we'll get through it y'all sov is a
monster he's had a little bit of hiccups
lately but he's one of my favorite
fighters to watch in the bantamweight
division uh megamod an KV and Johnny
Walker obviously magamed is a big
favorite in this for he does everything
well uh Johnny Walker is that guy where
he can spinning back kick spinning elbow
a knee so that fight so interesting to
watch could be a Domination by mamed but
Johnny Walker it could pull it off with
a flying knee some crazy crap like that
and could be fighting for a title if he
does I'm rooting for Johnny Walker would
not bet on it though uh in the the
co-main event Kar Usman hamzat Islam Mev
and Alexander vonavi in the main
event there's it here's the issue so if
I'm betting on this you're going to take
Hamza you're take
Islam and the odds are really on your
side here cuz when guys go up a weight
class especially fighting for a title
especially fighting a top Contender
they're like two and 40 I think in the
UFC the odds are not good when it comes
to Alexander volkanovski I I usually
don't care about the odds because the
the same rant I went on about Izzy and
being special volcanos is that special
of a fighter as well so when it comes as
a a fighter like that I don't care too
much about the odds when I hear 2 and 40
I'm like yeah but Alexander volovski no
one has bigger wos ever in the UFC than
Alexander vovi it's the two biggest
Australian nuts of all time on 10 days
nose fight ISO makev is insane this
guy's always in
shape but you you you it's you can't be
in a eight-week fight Camp shape like he
was for the first fight against Islam
his biggest tool and if you remember on
the broadcast Dominic Cruz alluded to
this his biggest asset at 155 is his
cardio
I don't think Alexander's out of shape I
I do think he'll be able to go five
rounds I don't think he'll be able to
push the same way he was in that first
fight which I thought he won same and I
he W was able to pull that off in the
transitions in the Striking game the
kicks the tenacity the takedowns because
of his cardio if that cardio let's say
his cardio is at a 10 for that first
fight let's say it's at a nine this time
it's you're going to get a different
fight the odds are so stacked against
Alexander pull this off who who do I
want to win who am I picking volkanovski
I think you beat him the first time but
if you tell me vovi on 10day notice and
even though he's a world class athlete
and his and his cardio is damn good but
on 10 days it's not a 10 it's a nine I'm
picking Islam every all
day I'm I want Alexander win I'm hoping
Alexander wins but off 10 days and his
cardio is not at that elite elite level
which makes him basically the Lance
Armstrong of the UFC and he's able to
just you know weather the storm get
takedowns especially late in the rounds
if that's even off a a little bit is on
Wednesday's fight you're getting a
different fight You're Expecting the
same result as the first time against
Islam Al Alexander banovski you're s Sly
mistaken because it's a 10-day notice he
have a full Camp his cardio is not going
to be the same he's going to fight
different now is that enough to pull off
something and knock Islam out maybe
that's what you're hoping for the issue
is when you take a fight in 10-day
notice I don't care what fighter you are
the odds are against you in every facet
it's not good for for Alexander it's
good for the fight fans good for the UFC
good for the brand good for Islam not
good for Alexander banovski that this
gonna be a much tougher fight Islam's
coming with a different game plan
Alexander is gonna have to come with a
different game plan his cardio's not a
10 even out of nine it's gonna be tough
to pick him over Islam but I I in my
heart of hearts I want Alexander win
this fight I still think he's the best
fighter on the roster in the main event
and Kamar Usman
you guys know how high I am on Hamot oh
actually that's the co-main event hamzat
Kamar is the co-main event it's
backwards on this thing sorry
um for Hamza and Kamar
Usman um this fight probably should
happen at 70 now it's happen at
85 no one hangs off hot's hairy nuts
more than me I think he's the next
champion at middleweight uh at light
heavyweight he can do it all
but it is interesting even though I'm
such a fan when you look at his run to
the title he's never fought a
middleweight he beat Kevin Holland at a
catchweight that was his last fight he's
supposed to fight Nate Diaz he fought
Kevin Holland now he's figh Kamar hman
Kamar hman is not a middleweight in any
facet the winner of this fight the
winner of this
fight the winner of this fight fights
for the title he's going to be the only
guy that's ever just jumped over weight
classes and never beat an actual
middleweight and then become a world
champion so he fought Gerald mot which
was um now remember that because of a
quick turnaround so Gerald mot he beat
him in 17 seconds right but then after
that he fights uh uh your boy my boy
yeah Lee and they fought Gilbert Burns
right at welterweight fought Kevin
Holland so his run to the title he
bought he fought Jedd motw on short
notice that's why it's at middleweight
but think about this then he fights the
leech Gilbert Burns Kevin Holland Kevin
Holland was a catchweight at 180 so his
run and I know he's fought middleweight
previous right he's fought middleweight
in Brave uh CF he fought uh in 2020 at
middleweight John Phillips but those
aren't world- class
middleweights his run now remember he's
at welterweight Miss weight fought Kevin
holl at 180 and then fights Kamar Usman
who's not a natural middleweight but
then if he wins his fight odds already
will he'll fight for World tied up
middleweight and then he's actual fight
middleweights like legit world class
middleweights it's insane it's awesome
it's a yeah do do Gilbert Burns Out of
Nowhere was already insane crazy yeah
and for kamaro Usman who again 10day
notice it's bad for Camaro it's bad for
Alexander banovski uh this be a tough
fight if kamaro been had two years to
plan for this car Kamar Usman has bad
knees so I don't know how much wrestling
we're going to get out of this so then
he's going to be forced to just strike
with a much more powerful striker in
hamzat he doesn't utilize leg kicks um I
don't know in what aspect Camaro can
beat him it's MMA I said the same thing
about Strickland is he who knows he
could land something he does have power
he doesn't have hamzat power so I think
he's be forced to strike with Hamot he's
not the most technical striker in the
world he's going to get in some trouble
and get
koed but I but I I do think it should be
said don't think that Kamar hman is a
washed up welterweight because he lost
twice to Leon Edwards I think your
takeaway from that should be godamn Leon
Edwards is that good and he was winning
the first Le Ed he was dominating the
first fight got head kicked and then the
the second fight not terrible outing you
know not the best but that's you got to
remember that's how good Leon Edwards is
because before that he dominated
welterweight ran to Leon Edwards just
how it goes so don't take this as oh no
Kamar usman's washed up he's jumping up
the middleweight it's actually a pretty
good spot for him to be in because Leon
Edwards doing his thing against Kobe
there's not a lot going guess you could
fight B Muhammad right and for Camaro
he's like man this isn't enough for me
now 10 days notice he fights Hamot if he
wins that Dana White has guaranteed him
or Hamot get the next title fat
middleweight so this is his fastest
track to get to a championship so you
know odds are stacked against him it's a
nightmare of a match up for him but
heavy lies the crown you want to be the
champ this what it gets you have to you
have to walk through Hamot now remember
two even though it was a long time ago
if he were to beat Hamot he fights
Strickland who we already
beat so there's that narrative too he's
he always has a win over Strickland so
it's all for the UFC it's good business
either way but very very tough fight for
him and I think this is the first time
I've seen Replacements before
Replacements last minute we'd be like a
that sucks but these are badass
Replacements these are better than the
original it's that crazy kamaro I was
like what paoo Paulo who when before I'm
a huge Paulo fan but oh that's crazy now
as a Hamza and I want him to have a
legit win over a top tier middleweight
that would have been good before he
fights for a title but I'll take Kamar
hman yeah all
day I can't wait I'm excited all right
kids that's it I got to rush over the
firing kids because we have Adrian
Peterson coming on and I'm GNA try to
prevent Ken from talking about him being
black and giant so we'll see how that
goes uh Niagara Falls almost sold out
November 3rd and 4th one show November
3rd one show November 4th that's Friday
Saturday Niagara Falls New York York
that's at the senica casino out there
bad boys are almost sold out and then
Chicago we will add shows if we have to
we're getting close February I'm sorry
February December 8th and 9th that's a
Friday and Saturday in Chicago two shows
Friday two shows Saturday get your
tickets now those bad boys are selling
out as well we have a bunch of other
dates on there so get you some at thick
boy.com but Niagara Falls I will see you
soon November 3rd and 4th that's it kids
enjoy the fights this freaking Saturday
take it in it's going to be a great one
be nice to each other stay safe I have a
bunch of news as far as my car and truck
content and the new show we're launching
with that so stay tuned love you guys be
nice I'm
out